So go ahead and fix a problem that calls the
error. So here's my query to get the conferences right, order
by name, so let's just take that off. We don't want
to order by name right there, instead, we want to order
by max attendees, we put that right after we add
the filter for it. But we still want to order by name,
so let's just add that second sort order in here. Then
you can go ahead and test the function. Just make sure
that you actually have some conferences that satisfy
all these criteria, otherwise you won't get any results.
So let's say you've got this query, to
get all the conferences. How would you update it
to filter for conferences in Tokyo, where there's
at least one but less than ten seats available?
And the results are sorted by the number seats
available, the name of the conference, and the month.
So when you figured it out, go ahead and enter the code here.